esta es una captura de pantalla de un
ejercicio de khan academy y dice la
siguiente gráfica interactiva contiene
la gráfica de y es igual a logaritmo en
base 2 de x como una curva punteada y
puedes verlo aquí abajo como una curva
punteada con los puntos resaltados 1 0 y
2 1 ajusta la gráfica móvil para dibujar
que es igual a 4 x logaritmo en base 2
de x 6 menos siete y si tienes este
ejercicio frente a ti te invito a
hacerlo o si sólo lo estás pensando en
tu cabeza piensa como lo abordaría te
daré una pista para pasar del original
logaritmo en base 2 de x
a todo esto realmente va a ser una serie
de transformaciones y en la herramienta
que tenemos aquí podemos mover esta 5ta
vertical y luego también podemos mover
dos de estos puntos
entonces vamos a empezar justo aquí esta
es la gráfica de y es igual a logaritmo
en base 2 de x así que hagamos estas
transformaciones una a la vez lo primero
que voy a hacer es que en lugar de hacer
solo el logaritmo en base 2 de x
voy a hacer logaritmo en base 2 de x + 6
de modo que si reemplazo la x con x 6
que va a suceder bueno va a mover todo 6
a la izquierda y si eso no tiene sentido
intuitivo para ti te invito a ver
algunos de los vídeos introductorios
sobre transformaciones de desplazamiento
entonces todo se desplazará 6 a la
izquierda está asintóticas se desplazará
6 hacia la izquierda en lugar de estar
en x igual a cero va a estar en x igual
a menos 6 este punto que estaba en 10 va
a moverse 6 a la izquierda 1 2
es 456 y este punto 21 va a moverse
6 a la izquierda 1 2 3 4 5 y 6 hasta
ahora lo que hemos graficado es
logaritmo en base 2 px
6 lo siguiente que queremos hacer es
cuánto es 4 por logaritmo en base 2 de x
6 y quiero que pienses que cualquiera
que sea el valor de ye que obtuvimos
antes ahora vamos a obtener 4 veces eso
entonces cuando x es igual a menos 5
obtendremos un valor de ye igual a 0
pero 4 por 0 sigue siendo cero entonces
ese punto se mantendrá igual
pero cuando x es igual a menos 4
obtenemos un valor de igual a 1 ahora va
a ser cuatro veces mayor porque estamos
poniendo este 4 al frente
así que en lugar de ser igual a 1 ahora
va a ser igual a 4 de modo que esto que
tenemos aquí es la gráfica de y es igual
a 4 por logaritmo en base 2 de x 6 y
luego lo último que tenemos que
considerar es que vamos a tomar todo eso
y vamos a restar 7 para llegar a nuestra
gráfica objetivo entonces cualesquiera
que sean los puntos que tenemos aquí
ahora les vamos a restar 7 de modo que
este está en e igual a 0 pero ahora
vamos a restarle 7 así que vamos a bajar
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 salía un poco de la
pantalla pero dejen de ver si puedo
desplazarme un poco hacia abajo para que
puedan ver eso ahí lo tienen ahora lo
pueden ver movi esto de 0 a menos 7 y
luego tengo que bajar este 7 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 y hemos terminado ahí lo tienen
esta es la gráfica de y es igual a 4 por
logaritmo en base 2 t x 6 menos 7
y hemos terminado